oh my God I love my B is Idle most of
them are you kidding me yeah yeah espe
love it yeah yeah yeah hi guys you smell
good angel angel I was like that star
thing yeah I love that smells so good it
looks like the little star and I spray
so much of it that I go through a bottle
like in two weeks you know what I can't
do it I doesn't it doesn't last on me I
spray perfume it and nobody's ever like
you're not spraying enough K I know but
then I feel like okay I'm not good at it
I need lessons congrat congratulations
on the the Golden Globe Nom that's
incredible oh my God I mean we're both
from the same show you know what I'm
saying like so it's like I never thought
I'd be doing this you never thought like
I never even thought I'd being in an em
category never think you being these
categories that we're in like is this
just blowing your mind it's like a dream
like my when my husband I was in LA I
was stuck in La I was supposed to be in
New York and uh yeah they kept pushing
the flight back but um my husband we we
talk every morning it's my best friend
and I called home and everybody was
screaming so I hung
up it thought something was wrong oh
you're like no bad news no bad news so I
call back and I'm like baby you got to
calm down tell me what's wrong he's like
you got a nominated for a Golden Globe
and literally here was here's what I
did oh my God my favorite part is that
you hung up I had to bye didn't know
that something like this could happen
for you know we just love to sing that's
what I'm saying you had like a dream and
then it kind of you you said yes to
opportunities that may well actually you
didn't say yes to this opportunity at
first which is crazy to me because you
player on the Broadway you're incredible
on Broadway and like it seems like such
a natural progression why' you say no it
was so heavy on Bradway kills um I was
stand out that role eight shows a week
plus my life was a bit crazy then so it
felt like I was carrying my cross and
her cross yeah that was a overload yeah
and so this time when Scott called I was
thinking did you not see all the
interviews and I said I would never ever
come back felt challenged by it and he
just said you know you're you're our
ceing the our director Blitz he called
and when he told me he was giving sely
an imagination I said I'm in because we
all have an imagination and when we're
in bad places we imagine ourselves in
better places yeah you need it yes so I
was like I'm all in on Broadway you
didn't get to see how she worked out her
she goes through goes through goes
through and then and I'm here and
everybody's like Yay but how did you get
here yeah so I was just very excited
that they gave her an imagination
yeah it is hard when you're going
through life stuff I was talking to
Jason about that too you go through life
stuff and you have to compartmentalize
and also do your job that's hard and
when you're in a better place you're
like I won't go there why would I do
that get it get it get it get it
do you I'm just curious cuz I was forced
to cuz I had to do something and say yes
to something like to let them see it
have you ever seen you on idol do you
ever watch yourself on idol like have
you ever done that I do you know a good
glass of wine always sends me back I kid
you not my husband's here I will
literally go
back now and I don't know if you like me
I hate watching myself I hate watching
myself but if I've had a good glass of
cab um there's not enough wine in the
world to like literally I watched it I
had to watch it and I found dude I feel
like if I got through that I can do
anything yes anything give me another
anything I was like I did that and it
was hard I was tired I was over a lot I
know anyway um let's do another short
commercial break everybody The Color
Purple is in theaters Christmas Day
y'all got to check it
out
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home